good morning
here i am again steve here steve cochman
to talk about
how i'm doing in my 90 day challenge to
engage with all of you who are following
me live or who
follow this video later on at youtube
and i'm sure many of you are involved in
this 90-day challenge as you know i am
working on
arabic and persian i'm sort of focusing
in on on arabic a little more now
because the persian first of all the
persian is easier second of all i have
an opportunity to speak persian in
vancouver or we'll have when i'm back
there
and the arabic is more difficult and so
i want to kind of get a better toehold
on arabic i might go five days arabic to
this persian
but i want to talk a little bit about
reviewing words because i'm now doing
with my arabic i'm doing a little more
review
because i wanna it's difficult with the
writing system and all
but i'm gonna show you examples of how i
review but i'm gonna use portuguese
because we have a lot of
i'm sure a lot of people watching don't
read arabic and so i'm gonna use
portuguese i know a lot of you are
portuguese speakers from brazil mainly
and so what i'm going to show you is how
i do it
and you may know from previous
discussions that i very much believe in
the random
random nature of of language
uh and of how we go about learning
languages i like doing it in a random
way it keeps things fresh
so uh you know i bounce around in terms
of the content that i use difficult easy
uh
varying it
uh if we are involved in a conversation
with someone a natural conversation we
have no way of knowing what they're
going to say to us so that the
experience can be quite random
uh words repeat
uh in a very much random way when we're
reading or listening or speaking so the
whole experience is random i'm not a
great believer in the idea that we have
these building blocks that we learn
certain basic uh you know
principles and then we build on that
rather it's this
bombardment of exposure to the language
that our brain gradually sorts through
so uh sorry to disappoint some of you
i'm not a great believer in
his base repetition because even if you
even if it is true that some kind of an
algorithm-based space repetition system
is more effective you would then end up
spending so much time reviewing that you
would have a little time for this sort
of interesting
listing
more random exposure to things and even
if you think you have learned something
through sort of deliberate study using
your flashcards you're going to forget
it again
and some words stick and other were
other words don't no matter how hard you
try to remember them so all of these
things make the whole experience
somewhat random so i am going to share
my screen
and show you but it's go it's going to
be a little bit artificial because it's
going to be portuguese but at least that
way more people will understand what is
going on
and i want to promote portuguese as a
great language to learn uh it's spoken
on
at least three continents it's spoken
therefore in obviously in brazil in
south america it's spoken in
in
portugal and europe it's spoken in
angola mozambique
on the continent of africa
and quite honestly they don't speak much
portuguese and macau but it may be that
there are other parts of asia where they
speak portuguese but it's a major world
language major world language such as is
russian such as this chinese such as his
arabic and turkish and there's lots of
major world languages not just english
but let me just demonstrate then with
portuguese
screen share
over here
all right now
presumably you can all see this so this
is the
uh portuguese
uh lesson feed at
okay we have this funny little symbol
which combines the portuguese flag and
the brazilian flag
is always difficult what do we use we
typically use the country
where the language originated so we use
the spanish flag for spanish even though
there's more spanish speakers in latin
america but we decided that since the
interest in portuguese is so
overwhelmingly for
you know by people who want to connect
with brazil so we kind of split the flag
half brazilian have portuguese i hope
you don't offend anyone
uh so but if i look at my lessons here
what i have studied in the past because
i did learn portuguese
at
link
ah
now
one lesson one course that i've used a
lot is this uh course called cafe brazil
so i will open cafe brazil
and
uh
you know and we have
tons of these from cafe brazil and
they're really quite good so we'll open
the one
here i don't know why it's up there it's
got 13 new words for me
and so we'll open it up
so now first thing is you heard a
portuguese voice doing the text to
speech so i want to remind you
that you can control that so for
whatever reason this was set up with the
portuguese female voice doing the
text-to-speech we're going to change
that
to a brazilian
male
brazilian portuguese male okay
close
so now
so we've now got a brazilian
so do remember that in these various
languages you do have very often you
have the choice of
what kind of an accent you want to
listen to
granted text-to-speech is not ideal we
do have
the natural voice
[Music]
so this is a great
he's a great uh you know
very animated uh podcaster and so it's a
great lesson or a great course to use
one of the things as you go through now
when i'm going to
as i'm going through saving words and
phrases i'm thinking about what i would
like to review
when i turn the page
now
uh first of all anything that is not a
word
so that's not a word so a high hit text
is gone okay
and
use your key strokes to make it easier
so
known as k
uh non-word for example
okay so again stephen i have my my right
arrow
anything i go back and forth using the
arrows stephen is not a portuguese word
i hit x
covey is not a portuguese word i hit x
so those are now eliminated they will
not be links they will not count in my
statistics all right now
it may be that sometimes you know
volcantar i'm going to tell you
volcan
i'm not really sure
i will say that because that's
well i know the meaning there i want to
say that as a phrase that i'm going to
work okay similarly here
may not be
phrases that i may i know what it means
but i maybe don't use them all that well
uh
cadavers
fees so sometimes tenses can
can be a problem so
okay
okay now i'm not i'm you know i don't i
normally do it on my ipad there is a
reason why this is not
saving but with a sheet i'll show you
a shake a shake is also good to have as
a saved phrase because it deals with the
tense and it deals with a word that
exists in portuguese that doesn't exist
in spanish so with that we just save a
few more just as an example
so if i put my uh cursor there
is also an interesting phrase to say so
i say
okay so then i turned one page now i
have to now here in going through these
cards you want to use your keystrokes to
keep it fast so it says here for example
press enter to flip the card uh okay
press enter
ah and now that's not very difficult i
don't know how it got saved so i want to
get rid of that so i can hit k
that gets rid of it that because you'll
see here that it's what i can hit two
three four to advance it so as you'll
see that if it's a two it's reviewed in
three days
uh
seven days
30 days
or known so if i want to make this known
volcan but i'll make this a three
because i want to look at it again
okay now i i have an opportunity
to
under the escape
practice writing
okay
now
here again cut off sk i can move that to
three i just hit three
how's that again if you want to repeat
it
okay well that's not very difficult but
the point is you determine
the difficulty
of okaying i didn't hear it properly see
the the dictation is very good because
it forces you to listen more carefully
king who okay make that a three
okay so the point that i wanted to make
here is that
i go through now let's get out of this i
go through no sorry we'll do this again
hold on
so you can
you can decide in your review settings
you can decide which of these different
flash cards you want to do
sometimes in my arabic i just do
dictation because i want to improve my
knowledge of the writing system
you can sometimes you don't want to do
multiple choice or closed tests so you
can very much determine which activities
you want to do
and how many do you want to do
and all of these things you determine
and i tend only to review
either i'll review when i turn the page
in a lesson or i can always go up here
and click on these links
and go through you know a solid dosage
of these phrases in whatever order i
want and i can save
phrases and then with the dictation i
have to type out the phrase which is
also kind of good
so
and i do it very much on a random basis
i'm in a lesson i'm turning the page i'm
going to review some words and phrases
um and again you'll notice that for
whatever reason when we bring in these
podcasts from cafe brazil there is this
funny
word that shows up so wherever that
shows up of course you have to eliminate
it okay
down here again
you have to try to control
what goes into your statistics
but uh i just thought i'd quickly review
that and then i want to hear
what sorts of experience you have had
with different forms of
of review uh how you use your the review
function at link or what other methods
you use to review your words okay so i
just thought i would start that to start
a conversation about reviewing
and i i again you know my pers my
approach to it is to make things random
i don't want to commit myself to
um
you know
a certain number a stack so to speak of
of of words that i have to review every
day because
there are you know literally like in
portuguese i have 20 000 words
there's no way that i would have enough
time to review all these words if i were
committed to a sort of a religious you
know uh review program so i make it
random i make it interesting and to me
it's just another way of
it's it's a form of concentrated
exposure to the language so is reading
stories listening you're just exposing
yourself to the language in different
ways another advantage of reviewing is
it's another thing you can do so when
you're tired of listening tired of
reading now you can do this other thing
which is review and you can also
adjust it so that you can include
dictation or not include dictation or
just do dictation so it introduces some
variety some randomness
and gives you a different form of
exposure to the language because it is
essentially through exposure to the
language that we're going to acquire
so enough of that now let's see
what sorts of comments and questions we
have here
[Music]
let's go to the very top here
salaam alaikum
says read all the time says listen
nearly all the time
okay
okay
read all the time
obviously
if i have dedicated learning time i read
so if i'm going to sit down here i read
not only do i read i read on my ipad
usually i save links and i review my
links
i listen
when i am doing other tasks i can't read
and vacuum but i have a quiet vacuum
cleaner and i can listen and vacuum i
can listen and do the dishes i can
listen and drive i can listen and work
out there's so many places where i can
listen and then
when i listen as i explained earlier in
my
little talk on curiosity
when i listen there's things i don't
understand so that makes me curious what
was that word and then i go and read it
so that listening triggers the reading
but absolutely reading is powerful i
find reading is better for acquiring
vocabulary especially when i do it in
the sort of link environment
and listening repeatedly listening to
similar the same content helps prepare
you for speaking so both are true
thank you for these daily live streams
says matthew you're most welcome
uh okay uh what does
keep your vocabulary okay what do i mean
by that
materials asked
by random i mean
because i don't i can't possibly review
all my 20 000 words in portuguese or
even my 8 000 words in arabic i can't
regularly review them i'm not going to
do a spaced repetition system where i
commit to reviewing these words
according to this sort of frequency
that's determined by an algorithm so
that every day i have to review however
many hundred words because i don't like
doing that i
i'm keen to
to read in arabic to listen in arabic
i'm looking forward to doing it and so
that the review then is sort of random
now and then
you know every so often i'm turning the
page or i'm motivated to look at
you know the the total number of links i
have in that course i'm going to review
them so i won't review all the words in
that course i'll review when i feel like
it okay
uh that's random so here's uh
lundy holbrook i try to read my german
flashcards all the time i find that
sometimes i question myself after i've
reviewed the same card many times yeah i
mean it depends what you like to do some
people like doing that i
don't particularly like it i think
having a variety of activities in the
flashcards
uh the way we do it makes it a little
more random you don't know what the next
card is going to be is it just a
flashcard is a dictation is it multiple
choice that keeps it fresh in a way
obviously multiple choice is much easier
than dictation for example
uh
but i always wonder after i finished the
session have i really learned anything
so
to me it's just
part of the exposure to the language
uh okay swedish finja manic file tells
me that in east timor they speak
portuguese are at least some of the
people though and they use only t-shirt
my son mark is down here i will talk to
him hey steve do you ever wake up in the
morning and feel completely unmotivated
to learn
languages
and so you take a little break
well because i'm committed to the 90-day
challenge
i would say there are very few days when
i don't do something
but um
you know because my main activity is
listening it's not that difficult to do
so i get up i'm gonna make breakfast
i might go to my playlist in arabic or
persian or i might go to a list to a
lesson because in the lesson i can
repeat it over and over again so i can
open a lesson let's say a mini story
that's five minutes long
i can listen to it a couple of times
then i go and read the lesson it's easy
i slide into it it's not it's not um
i know
yeah i would say that uh
basically
at least during this
um 90-day challenge
no every day i do something
it doesn't matter if we forget many
words and what matters is listening and
reading a lot so that these new words
will eventually stick into your brain
eventually absolutely that's correct i
don't worry about what i can't remember
okay could you add a grammar guide and
the many stories for swedish
i think we have some swedish many
stories we
are adding some more uh eric can tell us
if we have swedish grammar in the works
i'm not sure
uh is it reasonable to hear is from
aaron mclean burleson is it reasonable
to reach a level of fluency in a
language where you can one day learn a
third language in the second
oh no that's absolutely possible
absolutely possible and it becomes
possible when
you no longer feel that that's a big
deal you're almost as comfortable using
the second or third language to learn a
fourth language because you understand
most of the explanations
uh
you probably didn't notice but i had set
my dictionary language
to english of course but then had also
put in that i wanted explanations in
russian and korean
so yeah you certainly can do that
greetings from pr
steve pr i presume is puerto rico
i keep my chinese vocabulary coming from
articles that are of interest to me and
use pleco sr splash cards to function
but it sometimes gets boring how can i
attack this issue i find that
srs space repetition system is it starts
to dominate you and you feel that your
goal
is to go through all these flashcards
and i'm not convinced that you're
learning much if you are getting random
exposure to words through lots of
listening and reading
then you are not only getting that
random exposure you are also
getting better getting more fluent at
all of the other words that you already
know so
uh if i had eight hours a day to spend i
might set aside an hour for space
repetition flash cards but since i have
an hour to two most of which is
listening i have very little time for
flash cards
dk master steve if one were to do srs in
addition listening and reading would it
be more beneficial to learn common words
or rarer words
okay um
i mean certainly there's little benefit
to doing sp
based repetitions for very common words
because they will show up so often
anyway that you'll get plenty of
exposure to them
if there is a use for space repetition
then it would be more for the uncommon
words
um
okay when i usually use link i just
practice reading and looking at words
i'm not sure of all the time yeah that's
kind of the way i do it
do you
okay so advice to someone taking the
ielts test lots of listening and reading
use link
uh i mean all these tests basically
test your comprehension therefore your
vocabulary therefore your listening
comprehension
therefore to get there you have to
listen and read a lot i don't think
there's any shortcuts studying lists of
words that are likely to show up i don't
think in the end is going to prepare you
okay so john kr is now a little bit
unmotivated to study his russian i mean
you can't fight it if you're not so
motivated then you lay off until you the
motivation returns
do you make an effort to remember the
gender of a noun and do you confuse a
confused masculine feminine words when
you speak of course i mean i make a
you know
okay arabic
uh i'm i'm aware that this masculine
feminine that feminine tends to end with
an a
uh i i'm sort of you know conscious of
the fact that uh you know a led
uh
some of these things are gonna give me
hints as to
the actual uh but i don't worry about it
because
most of my effort is is comprehension
and listening and reading so it doesn't
affect my ability to understand what i'm
listening to when reading
and i don't do a lot of speaking
uh but i think i'm getting used to
certain phrases
where i would naturally start
uh
you know getting the gender right i
don't but but it's it's it's like
grammar you can review it from time to
time you'll probably forget it there are
some rules that are helpful
you can review it from time to time but
gradually with enough exposure and
practice and use and getting it wrong
you will gradually improve
uh i'm getting heavy amounts of
comprehensible input through reading
books and listening to podcasts but i'm
having trouble increasing my active
vocabulary says
sorry
yeah
to to get better at i mean all of the
input activity is increasing your
passive vocabulary which will gradually
these words will convert to active but
eventually you have to speak a lot okay
to speak well you have to speak a lot
and
the reason why passive vocabulary is so
important is you want to speak you want
to have meaningful conversations
so therefore you want to talk to people
about subjects of interest so you have
to understand what they're saying
so therefore you need a large passive
vocabulary and then gradually you start
using more and more of what you've
learned and you gradually get better at
it but it doesn't happen quickly so
people shouldn't be discouraged that
their inability to activate vocabulary
i think it's very important always to
remind yourself that six months
ago you couldn't say anything or you
couldn't say as much so that
give yourself credit for what you're
doing and and that'll keep you positive
but it is a slow process
how long have you been working on
language daily well if i include my
listening it's got to be up to two hours
a day
uh a few years ago in learning english i
used to use anki a lot as a beginner but
as i progressed in the language i
stopped now i'm trying to learn
french i use anki yeah i mean i haven't
used anki per se
but i i'm just personally not so
motivated to sit down and review a bunch
of words uh i'm more motivated to get at
some content and as i explained to do a
bit of random review
uh steve do you have a goal of what you
want to accomplish every day at link no
i don't i don't have a goal or whatever
it's it's driven by my listening
by the mood of the moment
uh
okay which language
should one prioritize the stronger the
weaker one
uh i mean the weaker one needs more
effort the stronger one will will
survive with relatively little effort
to go from b to c one how often would
you recommend speaking
sessions with a tutor
um
i mean these upper levels
are
quite demanding and uh
but as always comprehensive vocabulary
are a big part of it so i wouldn't just
speak with a tutor but to
say i'm c1 you have to be able to speak
well
and therefore
what i would do is i would say i would
start with three times a week
and if you feel you can benefit from
doing more but there will be times when
you feel that
you want to spend that time and because
we only have x amount of time so do you
want to spend that hour speaking to a
tutor
where you may be going over some of the
vocabulary that you already have or do
you want to spend that time trying to
enrich your vocabulary i think this is a
matter of trial and error
so you know in terms of retaining our
vocabulary uh if you leave a language
you'll lose a bit but when you go back
to it you'll recover it quite quickly
and vocabulary that you forget and
relearn tends to stay with you so it's
not something to worry about
uh yeah i find that the the question
here is whether you have to review your
vocabulary more at the beginning i think
that's probably true at the beginning
when you're you're having so much
trouble making sense of anything
um
that you know the sort of reviewing of
flashcards is sometimes easier than
listening or reading so it gives you
something else you can do
to give you exposure
uh concentrated expo exposure to these
new phrases
so that
uh i think it's something we do more of
at the beginning review because it's
something that we can get some sense of
achievement and satisfaction whereas
reading and listening is still such a
struggle it's such a struggle to
understand
what stops me from understanding
everything here in movies
is the use of slang what do you
recommend for this well
uh
first of all in watching these movies if
they use a lot of slang you'll start to
get used to some of it
also if you can find content
that you can transcribe then you could
study
content
podcasts or something that is heavy to
slang or you can in fact using the
browser extension on link and if the
uh movie has if it's on youtube and it
has
closed captions you can study that as a
lesson in other words you have to you
hear stuff that you don't know you don't
understand
you got to save it see it again see it
again and slowly it becomes part of your
vocabulary
uh i never review words but i should not
necessarily should you do what you want
to do
um
ram okay a number of view words what is
the best way to learn vocabulary
effectively
link
let's see lots of listing and reading
and random review
are the grammar types in link that tell
you the tense
manually added
no they're not manually added they're
not always accurate it's a software that
tries to guess what
part of speech and so forth it is
uh it does you can click through to the
grammar review and they're not there for
all languages
but for the major languages we have that
luke connor
he appreciates these q a sessions that's
great i enjoy doing them
which is the most important tense in
english there is no more important tense
in english and i don't even think
there's a more difficult tense you just
have to get used to it it's all it's
again it's random
the present tense i would say one thing
that when in doubt use the simple form
so rather than trying to use the
continuous form use the simple form i
went
i not i had gone or whatever just keep
it simple and it'll help you
um
okay
looking good today yeah i had slept
really well last night uh some days some
evening nights you sleep better than
others what do you think of drilling of
repeating a sentence several times
well again it's it's whatever you're
you're willing to you know it's your
threshold of pain but i don't do a lot
of drilling i don't do exercises i don't
answer questions i like exposing myself
to interesting content and doing the odd
little bit of random review
uh but i can understand up to early
intermediate company it feels like i'm
stuck okay nicos
for korean a lot of risk reading and
listening and link but
feels he's stuck korean i found the same
it's very difficult the reasons are that
the dictionaries are
you know and i'm talking about good
dictionaries like naver which we have at
link
uh very often
the uh
dictionary hint is not applicable to the
content the google translate for korean
is not very good uh it's it's just a lot
of you and and i think we lack good
intermediate content at link i wish we
had more
i'm going to go back to korean starting
in june
i want to elevate my level but korean is
one of these languages that's uh that
i've found that i've kind of got a
little bit stuck at i have the feeling
that the same is going to happen with
arabic
it typically happens where there's not a
lot of intermediate content
different writing system
dictionaries don't often give you a very
good indication of the meaning all of
those things work you know make it more
difficult for korean and arabic than
let's say for french or russian
blah blah blah speaking of importing
subtitles there is a chrome extension
for neck place called sabadab okay um
eric might be making a note of that
uh
okay
we all know that hi i'm from brazil
parabens
amazing
thank you so much for answering my
questions according to your podcast
uh here said i've been learning chinese
for a few months and i would also like
to start on korean but i'm afraid i'll
get lazy at keeping up the chinese what
should i do
well i would
i would advise against hopping around
too much until you get to a fairly good
level i mean but again motivation is so
important if you're motivated to do
uh korean go and have a look there to
see if you can maintain
both of them you may find that you're
more motivated you may find that if you
do a bit of korean you become more
motivated to go back to chinese i think
you you know language learning is
ultimately a personal thing do what you
like to do
how do you recommend learning a language
when you already reached b2c1 just with
passive exposure such as listing the
language or still with looking up every
vocab you don't know well
you know i am b2c1 let's say in russia
not necessarily that i speak it so well
but in terms of my vocabulary my
comprehension is very good still if i
come across an article
on the internet or whatever i will tend
to bring it into link even with german
bring it into link because i can read it
so quickly and i can immediately you
know any new word will be highlighted in
blue that's what i prefer to do
on the other hand i also read books
paper books
in i don't know polish check where
there's quite a few words that i don't
understand i never looked them up so if
i'm on the ipad computer i'll look it up
if i'm reading a book i just let it go i
don't look things up in the dictionary
because it's simply too time consuming
and you very quickly forget
whatever typically as i've said before i
close the dictionary i've already
forgotten what i saw in the dictionary
okay
uh salam i'm english learner how many
words should i have to be a great
speaker you got to get up to 15 to 20
000.
how many languages can you speak and
which language is so easy okay well
you know
i'm on my 19th and 20th language in
persian and arabic
uh i can speak
limited arabic persian i have simple
conversations
uh the top 10 languages i can speak
comfortably on a variety of subjects
the next
declining degree of proficiency
let's put it that way how do you deal
with the feeling of being overwhelmed by
information i can barely speak three
languages so far i can only imagine
um i you know i i there are times when
i'm trying to look for some
word in language a and everything that
comes to mind is in language x
yeah it happens but once you kind of
move into that language
then that doesn't
bother me
is another
so to increase vocabulary
i mean that's what link was designed for
to increase vocabulary in other words
lots of listening and reading
but an easier way of looking up words of
making sure that you remember that
you've seen these words before the
opportunity to do
some occasional review and the fact that
everything is there convenient
for you content in our libraries the
ability to import stuff so it's it's a
place where you can in a
structured way expose yourself to a lot
of hopefully interesting content did you
find the spanish pronunciation became
much harder than french as an english
speaker no definitely not i would say
that
spanish pronunciation is relatively easy
because
their
vowels are
pure as is the case in japanese
the language is written the way it's
pronounced
uh that's not the case in french so no
on balance i would say spanish is easier
to pronounce than french
charles powell you got it
for any language learning issue steve's
golden rule of thumb is just do more
listening in reading yes
try to learn chinese how can i review
chinese vocabulary well it's no
different than any other language except
that you have to put that specific
effort into learning the characters so
that's
uh
you know
that's a separate
area of effort fifteen thousand worse
does a verb with all of its conjugations
count as just one no the way we count
the words of link is that every form of
a word
is identified as a separate word that's
because that's the only way the computer
can count them
and
i think it's useful to save words in
different forms because
often they have different functions
different tenses very often there are
words that trigger different tenses so
you get used to
this tense being associated
with this like certain time words like
often or always or never will trigger
different tenses
or i used to so
i find it useful to save words in their
different forms as different words but
in any case the calculation is based on
each form of the word is counted
separately
bloodsucker says i know a lot of
vocabulary my target language i think i
speak right but my passive my passive
vocabulary is limited
okay most people's that's interesting
uh
to increase your passive vocabulary you
have to do a lot of listening and
reading expand the range of things if
you're focused on a certain kind of
content get into i don't know
history politics literature
science expand the range of of stuff
that you're listening to and reading and
review
uh those words as i say randomly and and
use the link method any advice on
practicing pronunciation speech swedish
actually is a little bit difficult to
pronounce because of their intonation
which is very difficult for a non-native
speaker to get and certain sounds like
huge
um
i i think it's like
anything else lots of listening try to
make sure that you actually hear it
and then practice getting that
intonation so again this is not just for
swedish it's for getting your tones in
chinese it's for english get a short
paragraph
listen to it say it link
and then try to
say that read that paragraph with the
same intonation even if you mispronounce
some of the words but try to get that
intonation occasionally record yourself
but focus on getting the intonation and
very often if you get the intonation
then you're getting phrases and then the
vocabulary or at least the pronunciation
of individual words will become easier
what do you think of the fluent forever
method i don't know what the fluent
forever method is
okay
so joseph likes pictures i don't use
pictures i find it distracting there's
so many words that have nothing to do
with pictures
it's not something that i do but if you
enjoy doing it fine that's good uh tips
on learning chinese characters with link
you have to have a separate system
when i did it i had to write the
characters out by hand in order to learn
them but
obviously at least you have the
advantage that you can see the opinion
but you should have some kind of a
separate system for the characters but
as you see these characters in link it's
going to reinforce them for you
on what basis do you choose your content
i i google i mean i start out with
what's in our library and then i google
and search for what's out there in the
case of arabic i found these com the
podcasts at persian there's a persian
online which is a wonderful resource and
it's more of an intermediate
uh has some intermediate content i
haven't been able to find that in arabic
but i google and see what i can find and
see what i can import into link
okay well i think what do we got here
i'm a blind person i'm learning if you
think it is harder for me
uh you know obviously
i can't speak because i haven't had that
experience but obviously listening has
to be a much bigger part
of your learning and
so therefore and the
you know
uh
i like to listen to
language content
uh
where i can access the transcript but if
you're blind that's not going to work so
you would have to have content
that has
explanations in your
native language to go with the target
language that you're listening to
uh mairo vergara excellent i totally
agree with him and he's he's also
someone that i have gotten to know
through uh you know skype and through
the internet
uh
okay
steve i do five hours of three hours of
reading i want to read fluency by next
summer what do you think about that if
you keep that up you will but at some
point you have to start
speaking
uh
more okay continuing your listening and
reading but you do have to start
speaking a lot in order to you know see
what you're missing see what your
problems are
uh so start speaking more if you can
okay so here again dark metamorphosis
he feels he's moving slowly language
learning moves slowly
uh so i one shouldn't
what you have to be careful not to feel
frustration you have to
sort of try to prevent yourself from
sliding into frustration so you feel
you're not one of the reasons we have
statistic link statistics is to remind
people that in fact they are increasing
their vocabulary
more and more of the pages are
full of white words and not so many blue
words uh you are improving
uh
but it but you shouldn't be like as the
famous german neuroscientist
said the brain learns the brain cannot
do other than learn it's constantly
reacting to you know
exposure experience but the brain learns
slowly so the key is to do things that
you enjoy doing so that you stay with it
if you spend the time you will improve
but don't say i'm not learning as
quickly as i would like or as quickly as
someone else it doesn't matter you will
eventually get there
how to write well in english
read a lot the more you read the more
words you have the more you see
or you read
things written by people who write well
this is going to improve your ability to
to write but eventually you have to
write so you have to actually do these
things so i would write every day i
would keep a diary
but also to enrich your language do a
lot of reading and listening
how can we come overcome inhibitions
when it comes to speaking obviously i
speak english pretty well but i've
recently been to london and i was so
inhibited i could speak
um
yeah i mean uh
the thing is
when we are communicating in a foreign
language and if you go to england the
chances are the people that you speak to
can only speak english so if to judge by
your name you might be polish i don't
know the fact that you can speak polish
in english means that you are better in
terms of language not necessarily a
better person but in terms of language
you're better than those people
uh
the fact that you have an accident the
fact that you look for words you're
speaking in a foreign language you know
if we wanted to be totally comfortable
we would never learn a foreign language
because speaking in a foreign language
it you sound more stupid you sound more
childish you sound less eloquent all
those things it's not as good speaking
in a foreign language is harder so you
just accept that you have to
it's part of you know i think
keeping things positive is is a big part
of language learning i'm improving six
months ago i couldn't do this or two
years ago i couldn't do this so now i'm
doing this and patting yourself on the
back
i mean it's easier said than done but
most people you're going to talk to if
you go to london most people you're
going to talk to
are only interested in communicating
they're not interested in judging your
language
and
i guess the what i find the most
sort of inhibiting
is when i can't understand
so
that's where it's i think part of a big
part if you're forever having to ask
someone to repeat something that's very
uncomfortable but if i struggle to say
something and look for words that
doesn't bother me and so therefore again
my emphasis is always on comprehension
if you can understand if i can
understand i feel comfortable if i
struggle to explain something that's
fine he'll wait i've never had a person
say well uh you know i've lost interest
in talking to you and i'm gonna go away
now it doesn't happen
so that's the only advice i can give you
daniel uh
just be happy that you're able to
communicate like if i went to again i
don't know if you're polish or not but
if i went to poland and i could
understand what people were saying and
and people
uh spoke to me and some people might
revert to english and that's fine
but a lot of people would communicate
with me in polish and i would make
mistakes but i would feel happy that i'm
able to communicate in polish but my
emphasis would be on a lot of listening
and reading so that i have a chance to
understand what they're saying
yeah this marco's yeah just keep going
absolutely yep
hey steve i got a question how can we
recall better new words my main issue is
i am exposing myself to a lot of
interesting content like link reading
lots of poems and books that i think how
can we recall better new words okay
there's no magic some words stick and
some don't and sometimes if you feel
that this word would be appropriate just
use it see what happens it may be right
it may not be right there'll be some
feedback
and uh
certain words will bubble up in a
conversation and i think we just have to
be brave enough to try to use them and
if we use them incorrectly it really
doesn't matter there's no great damage
done
so
uh but some words are forever gonna stay
hidden you'll recognize them uh you
would like to use them and you can save
them at link
i i find that the things that i want to
be able to do i save and link save as a
phrase then i do the dictation i find
the dictation
get the feeling might help me retain
some of those words and phrases better
and you just hope for the best
i retain just a few of them how can i
deal with it there's no dealing with it
like
whatever you can do is good
so in some words you simply can't
remember them then that's fine too as
long as you can communicate
uh chico
what is it
thank you so much for answering i am
indeed published okay
uh thank you so much for that answer
sometimes
i get really frustrated with myself it's
hard for motivation sometimes but i feel
happy when i see almost full white pages
now exactly that's motivation
how can i get out of intermediate level
musa intermediate is a good level
because you can actually read and listen
to interesting stuff i wish i were
intermediate
in arabic i'm listening to these
podcasts al jazeera and i can't
understand them i read them and i kind
of fight through it and i'm not yet
intermediate so it's more difficult for
me once you're intermediate you can
explore all kinds of interesting stuff
i have some words that i just forget 50
times and wonder how i keep forgetting
it just happens exactly some words are
not going to stick
some words are not going to stick and
some words for whatever reason sometimes
very rare words you remember them
steve your motivation to keep you
motivated all right
thanks steve
uh we met a few years ago in bath yes i
yes yes yes i remember adrian you i
thought you were english you spoke like
some regional form of
i don't know birmingham or something uh
english although if i remember correctly
originally from poland started japanese
to go on lincoln my progress was slower
than i was expecting yeah i mean some
people find first of all a problem with
japanese
is
the characters and i do
strongly recommend that people who are
seriously interested in japanese should
learn the characters and that is a task
in itself
and then
uh
you use link for the
words the the you know the good content
and you can see that for ghana you can
either have the fully gana or you can
have the romaji there so i i think it's
a tremendous way to advance but you have
to get that initial exposure to the
characters have a system for learning
characters
and i would also get a little starter
book like a teach yourself don't buy an
expensive one just a little bit of an
overview of the how the language works
not trying to remember anything and yeah
okay best wishes to carmen thank you
yeah we had a great
get-together there in bath
uh yeah aj hogg is a great guy there is
an accent from somewhere in the north of
england that i totally can't understand
and neither can most of english friends
i'm afraid of encountering something
like that in french
you know what there are people in quebec
that you would have trouble
understanding but most of the people in
the big cities and stuff you'll
understand in france
i can't think of an accent that's hard
to understand
okay thanks steve mr great week thank
you do you have any tips for memorizing
what i
put out a video where i said don't
memorize
don't memorize hindi if we get any if we
get content
we will put hindi up at link where we
don't have hindi yet somebody gave us
the many stories in gujarati so that's
what we have
how many times people you know in terms
of speaking
yeah you have to create the time so
either you find a language exchange site
or you pay for a tutor and
of italki
i find that twice
a week is fine two to three times a week
it's fine
the hardest words are the ones that
don't have something you can imagine
it's true it's true but i i think it's
even more random than that as to how
some words stick in some words though
uh okay i think i'm gonna call it here
and so thank everyone for listening and
enjoy your language learning
here's a few more quick keys here i'm
also learning japanese just reading
not progressing fast but you got to stay
with it yeah i'm an enemy level spanish
trying to improve listening concentrate
one way i'm doing that watching
telenovelas that's good is it better to
first learn spanish than french or vice
versa
um depends what you're motivated to do
but probably spanish is easier for most
people okay bye for now